[Music]
Angelina Jolie upset and fighting back
after her Vanity Fair tell-all ignites
the backlash yeah in that article she
opened up about Brad and the kids but
now Angelina is being accused of
mistreating impoverished children on the
set of her new film Jolie is getting
attacked online and being called cruel
and monstrous for a money game she used
to audition orphans for her latest movie
a new Vanity Fair cover story described
it this way quote the casting directors
set up a game rather disturbing in its
realism they put money on the table and
ask the child to think of something she
needed the money for and then to snatch
it away after the story went viral one
critic tweeted it was a kind of orphan
Hunger Games
Angelina fired back telling ET in a
statement it was false and upsetting
that people misinterpreted her
description and quote every measure was
taken to ensure the safety comfort and
well-being of the children on the film
the oscar-winning actress added I am
upset that a pretend exercise in an
improvisation from an actual scene in
the film has been written about as if it
was a real scenario meanwhile Vanity
Fair stands by its story the magazine
says its reporter clearly describes what
happened during the casting process as a
game she also points out that there was
a therapist on the set every day Joe
Lee's film first they killed my father
was shot in Cambodia that's also where
she adopted her first son Maddox Maddox
has been working on this since beginning
he's in the production he helped me with
this script and it isn't just because
he's my son it's because this film is
through the eyes of a child and we've
all had to open up a little bit more and
be like children
[Music]
you